They warned us that something was coming
If there is ever an end in this
forever war
It will be because of you and your strong right hand
I'm on your side!
Sorry, my bad!
Where the line in the sand
We fight against the forces of darkness. This is
You're expecting a sign that says secret headquarters. Oh
I need some ID love. Oh, are you serious?
He made me a damn weapon I
Just wanted to help you become the best
you
Some dads get their kids Legos
To be saving the world assignments
Does it do anything special yeah, it smashes things real good
You are mankind's best and only hope
We were supposed to be fighting monsters not working with them
Are you calling monster pal you look in the mirror recently he's an ass
Sorry for us you've arrived just in time
Hey everybody, we finally got that Hellboy footage a day early IGN dropped this trailer, so I guess they wanted it to post early
Whatever. We'll break it down
If you're new to the channel, be sure to subscribe to get all the videos the movies coming out next year
But there'll be plenty more trailers before that happens. Ok, so David Harbour wielding Excalibur on fire Milla Jovovich
Who's playing NEMA way the Lady of the lake aka the greatest of all British witches, who is the main villain of this movie?
So if it wasn't clear who she's playing and you haven't read any of the Hellboy comics
I'll try to explain because I think this is based
Somewhat on the Wild Hunt and they're using that as a sort of transition from the guillermo del toro
movies to explain how everything looks a little bit different
So at the beginning of that story Hellboy has been trapped in another world by another group
He comes back
So he has to sort of reintroduce himself to all these other people in mcshane, as you can see is playing his father professor
Brunton home, so it's an r-rated reimagining of the Hellboy character
that's why you meet all the BPRD characters and you actually go to the
BPRD for the first time like he makes the joke about the entrance in the trailer
They probably won't dedicate quite as much time during this movie to his
Origin story as the original Guillermo del Toro movies did the beginning of that movie started with the Nazis?
Summoning him to earth because hey, he's a really cool character
But there's this long-term prophecy about him bringing about the destruction of the world with the right hand of doom
That's what as big giant hand is called
So, of course, we got to say it David Harbour looks very different sounds very different from the Ron Perlman Hellboy
I have a very special place in my heart for those movies
The first one I still think is the best one but the story that it seems like they picked to base this new
R-rated version on sounds like it's going to be much bigger
If you haven't read the Wild Hunt and you don't know about Hellboy wielding Excalibur, it's actually a pretty cool story
but you hear Ian McShane give you a little bit of a teaser for the
Overarching story when he talks about the forever war and you see Hellboy walking to retrieve Excalibur
If you're not familiar with Hellboy mythology, this incorporates a lot of the mythology of the King Arthur Chronicles
You know in real life Arthur Pendragon knights of the round table Camelot all that
so within the world of Hellboy
The rules about wielding Excalibur is only descendants genetic descendants of King Arthur Pendragon
Can pull the sword out of the stone? Sometimes it will disappear for centuries then reappear
So it reappears during this story in hell boy is able to retrieve it surprised because he is the descendant of King Arthur
Marking him as the rightful king of Britain
So Hellboy who's sort of like this Prince of Hell?
Like he has the crown of flames that you saved in the keema deltoro movies
The crown of flames is also a nice reference to being the rightful king of Britain that enables him to wield
Excalibur and because of his demonic abilities, that's why he's able to light the sword on fire
But even if you're familiar with the King Arthur Chronicles because this is the world of Hellboy and it's sort of their spin
On the King Arthur mythology, the sword gives Hellboy a lot of extra powers
So because he's a rightful king of Britain wielding the sword
he actually gets to
Resurrect a lot of dead British knights to fight for him in this big war against NIM away
The story of her character is a little more complex
I don't know how much of it they're gonna do from the comic book, but she was the most powerful British Witch in history
But kind of a villain kind of crazy
so what happened is is that when she was killed they had to separate her body into a bunch of different pieces because she was
So powerful that if you laid her corpse pieces on top of each other
They would just reform her body and she would be resurrected
So you basically have to chop her body up and put all the pieces in different boxes so that her body can't reform
So when the British witches in present-day need a strong leader
they ask Hellboy he refuses they choose her and then grant a couple people permission to
Reform her body and bring her back to life
but because she's so powerful the Dragons of the
Apocalypse that have been in prison to choose her as their vessel to return to earth and destroy
Everything which I think is what this scene in the trailer is meant to imply the dragon flying over what looks like
London set on fire because obviously a lot of this feels very British because they're doing Excalibur they're doing the King Arthur Chronicles
British mythology, so it makes sense that the story takes place in England
But if you're not familiar with the Dragons of the Apocalypse is basically the Hellboy comics spin on the Book of Revelations
So in the Christian Bible, this is big reckoning for planet Earth
but in the Hellboy comics is
these special dragons that were imprisoned a long time ago by the right hand of do remember the hand the Hellboy has
attached to his body
So what we might wind up with in this movie
This is just me speculating is is that Hellboy wielding Excalibur will fight Milla Jovovich
--is nimah a character who becomes possessed by the dragons of the revelations?
So you literally have Hellboy Dragon Slayer with Excalibur. So the story feels like a very classic British
Myth like we just got that guy ritchie king arthur film. It didn't go over so well, but everybody has very well intention
So this is just a slightly different spin on that idea
But obviously that's just a quick once-over and the trailer doesn't give you a real big idea for how deep this goes
So if you're big fan of really cool
Mythology like that, I would recommend checking out some of the Hellboy comics starting with the Wild Hunt
There are only a couple things about the trailer that bother me
I'm not super hot on the pop song that they chose in some of the corny jokes that they tried to incorporate into this if
You're really bummed out. The guillermo del toro is involved with this. Don't worry. I believe he's given his blessing
Ron Perlman has also given his blessing to David Harper. David. Harper is a great actor
They're definitely
Swinging for the fence with the story in the scope that they're going with so it'll be interesting to see some of the subsequent trailers
Usually the first teaser trailer doesn't give you a really big idea about the story
but like I said
I think this is largely based on the Wild Hunt the Hellboy comics
Incorporating a lot of the King Arthur mythology into their stories is also a re-explore
ikan, textual ization of Hellboy's origin story itself
So even though it's not the origin story that we got with the guillermo del toro first movie
It's still an origin story of sorts
So I think they're trying to use it as a jumping-off point for people who may have never seen that original Hellboy film
So we'll see how far they go with it because if it does well, they'll probably do sequels
So we'll see where they continue but let me know in the comments what your favorite part of the trailer and what are you looking?
Forward to most if you are a big hell boy comic book fan to let me know
What's your favorite comic book story while you wait for everything click here for a bunch of brand new Game of Thrones?
Season 8 promos and click here for my brand new Avengers endgame video. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight